- I think people need to get,
sit down and clarify
what experiences are you really
looking for in your life?
So a lot of people now, "Well,
I want to have a clear head."
Go "Om." or drink or
something to clear your head.
- Yeah.
- As opposed to, wait a minute.
Why is this on my mind
and what do I need to do
to get it off my mind?
You need to make action
decisions when you're smart,
so that when you're dumb
you do smart things.
- He's a productivity consultant
best known for creating
the time management system
known as Getting Things Done.
His company focuses on
productivity action management
and executive coaching.
Time magazine called
his best-selling book,
Getting Things Done,
the defining self-help
business book of its time.
He's David Allen and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number four is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always, if David says something
that really inspires you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(dramatic orchestral music)
- I think people need to get,
sit down and clarify
what experiences are you really
looking for in your life?
And that doesn't necessarily,
it can include lots of money
but it can also include
what do you want to
experience with that money?
A sense of freedom? A sense of service?
A sense of providing value to the world?
A sense of self-confidence
and self-efficacy?
What is it that you're after?
So there's, in my own explorations
in the whole personal growth
and self-awareness game,
for years I've been involved
in that pretty seriously.
There's an exercise, let's
say, well what do you want?
I want a red Porsche. Great.
What experience do you think
that's going to give you?
Freedom and a sense of fun, whatever.
And then the people get the red Porsche
and they're worried about
somebody going to dent it
and they can't afford the payments on it.
They didn't really get the
experience they were looking for.
What happened?
They got the symbol
but they didn't get the inner experience.
But if you want the
experience of freedom and fun,
you can have that this afternoon.
Doesn't mean you shouldn't
have the red Porsche
but it just means that
if you start to focus
on the inner experience
what would climbing the
corporate ladder give you
as an inner experience?
Why do you want that?
What's important to you about that?
And it could be I want
to provide for my family
for after I'm gone.
So there's a sense of building wealth
or building net worth or building assets
for the people around
you that matter to you.
There's no right or wrong
about any of your answers to this
but I think getting clearer about
whether you want to do that or
whether you want to get there
because you want to be able to impact
a much larger segment of
the world for doing good
or taking it over, I don't know,
for whatever you want.
But I think that's the key
is being able to externalize
and start to become objective
about well what is it that you're after?
And so just crafting your own ideal scene
not only of the things you want
which is fine don't stop that.
Don't feel embarrassed that
you want a red Porsche.
So there's nothing wrong with any of that
material stuff that you might want
but it's also true,
that's a real good idea
to just say, let me just lay that all out
and then use that as a
map just to then guide you
in terms of your
intuitive decision-making.
I don't think you have
to work at it that hard
but I think you do need
to be conscious about it
and validate it in some part of yourself.
Most to-do lists are incomplete lists
of still unclear things by the way.
What you see on to-do
lists are things like
budget,
mom,
dog,
babysitter.
Well I understand this sort of
probably indicates something,
that's something you've
got to do something about
but what exactly is the work
you need to do?
And that's going to be the
second thing you need to do,
is to take those things
that you've identified
that are yanking your chain
and you need to make some
really specific decisions
about what does the work involve
and there's two key
questions you need to ask
about everything on your list.
What outcome am I committed to finish
so that you can define
that target out there.
What's the project about the budget,
about the dog, about the babysitter,
and identify those.
And then you need to ask yourself
what's the very next action
step that I need to take
to move forward on that
if I were going to move on it.
Outcome and actions,
zeros and ones of productive behavior.
What are we trying to accomplish?
How do we allocate
resources to make it happen?
But you need to apply
that very specifically
if you want to be appropriately engaged
with anything yanking
your chain out there.
The late great Peter Drucker,
you folks here know that,
would tell every one of
us as knowledge workers
the toughest admonition,
your toughest work is
defining what your work is.
He'd put it in broad terms,
this is very specifically
what he's talking about.
What is the work embedded in that
and getting very clear about that
and I guarantee you if you sat down
and take at least a few of
the things off your list
and make these decisions,
what's the project?
Write it down.
What's the action step?
You will feel exponentially
more appropriately
engaged with your world.
Never seen an exception to that.
- [Interviewer] Tell us when
you were just starting out,
now you're all big and successful,
back way long time ago in the day
when you were just first starting out,
what were your most successful
marketing strategies?
- Well I think if we're,
what we're talking about really
is building a business off of the brand
of building a business
off the Getting Things
Done model and methodology.
That actually developed many many years
after I was doing the work
in consulting and coaching
but I didn't market myself then.
Marketing was called pick up the phone.
It was all referrals whatever
but even back then I have to say,
job one called network engage
like don't turn down any
opportunity to talk to anybody
about what you're doing.
As long as they're positively inclined,
so if they're trying to talk to you,
beat you up or run you down
or prove that they're better than you
that's probably not worth while
but most people are
often gracious about that
and so you got to ask,
you've got to put yourself out.
So that's what I've done.
I've continued to do that.
As the book came out
then I had opportunities,
people would, I got press on that,
that the book publisher produced,
but I took advantage of
every single podcast,
every single interview,
every single like this.
Like you, Stephanie, meeting you,
saying "Hey David,
"do you want to talk to people?"
I go, "Sure, I'll talk to people."
So I'm not actually a
naturally extroverted person,
it actually is something
I do need to focus on.
And it's not like I get
all my juice out of that.
So it is a consciously done thing
and I think out of hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of interview requests
and would you write an
article about or whatever.
I think I've only turned down one
that just seemed to be a bit sleazy.
My wife is my chief executive assistant.
She provides a little
bit of a filter for me
about those kind of things
but I take advantage of all that.
So that's job one.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
Okay, so just saying yes
to every opportunity.
- Saying yes to every opportunity
and also just in terms of my stuff,
many times, much like
what Mr. Ford used to say,
he never, he never,
he learned what he knew
by talking to people
'cause he said he had a BS meter
that would go off inside of him
if he was talking to people.
That's where he learned.
And I'm pretty much the same way.
So it's not only a one way street.
meaning you're helping
other people out there
but I also matured a lot of my thinking
about what I was doing
and how to express it
by doing that.
- You're a guru of time management
and getting things done.
So give us the lay of the land
and then we'll do a little deep dive.
- You ready?
- Yes, I'm ready for this.
- Your head is for having
idea is not for holding it.
That's it.
- That's it?
- If you get that,
you now have the key to keeping
creative space in your brain
to be able to have a lot more room
to be a lot more creative,
have a lot more fun,
fulfill your life a lot,
a lot better.
Most people are walking around,
most 99.9999% of people
are still walking around
with the constipated psyche,
with all the stuff
they're trying to manage,
keep track of, remember,
remind themselves about or whatever.
And that is so suboptimal.
- My mouth is open because
I just, I just got it,
in that one sentence how profound that is.
And I think about what you want to say,
basically say it again
so that the world--
- Your head's for having
ideas, not for holding 'em.
- Your head is for having
ideas, not for holding them.
I'm guessing that's getting retweeted
around the world right now.
- That I need cat food should
pop into your head once.
If it pops in twice,
you're not handling your
appropriate engagement
with your cat or its food.
(laughing)
Right? I mean, why have an idea twice?
It's just the reason you do
and the reason things pop into
your head for the most part
is simply because you're not
yet appropriately engaged
with whatever that thing is
and it's got you as opposed to you got it.
So interestingly,
you have to learn the skill
and what I discovered and developed
and really recognized,
I didn't make it up,
this is nothing new.
- Sure. This is humanity that--
- Yeah, what I did was make explicit
what we implicitly do to get things done.
But the truth is
that you actually have to use your mind
to get stuff off your mind.
So a lot of people now, "Well,
I want to have a clear head."
Go "Om." or drink or
something to clear your head.
- Yeah.
- As opposed to, wait a minute.
Why is this on my mind
and what do I need to do
to get it off my mind?
And that actually requires thinking.
- Those are two very important questions.
- That's bad news for
everybody listening to this.
Thinking is required so the
brain can actually think.
- So let me try and apply that.
The worldwide audience
sitting in right now,
is largely creators,
people who are learning a new skill,
want to acquire a new skill in photo,
video design, art, music,
entrepreneurship, for example.
And I feel like if I'm going
to be the test monkey here
and apply what you just said to me
that when I,
my best moments
are when my mind really is the most clear.
It's the most sort of empty.
And I am able to take
on a thing and do it.
- Either your paints need to be organized
before you start painting.
- Right, 'cause then you
know where mustard is.
- You need a clear canvas.
- Where cobalt color is.
- Absolutely, I mean if
you're going to cook,
how do you want your kitchen to start?
You've got friends coming over in an hour.
- Is that why we clean our room
before we study for the test?
- It's why your car drives
better when you get it clean.
(laughing)
I coached one very senior executive
in a very large company
whose average backlog of email was 4,000.
His biggest issue was the fact
that his calendar was booked
for the next two months.
Hardly anybody could get
in because of his schedule.
Why was his calendar booked?
Because people couldn't get his input
to be able to okay or get his authority
to move on the things he
had tasked them to do.
They had to get in his face
so they needed a meeting.
After I coached him,
I've never seen anybody change
that significantly that fast
but then his backlog
went from 4,000 to zero.
What happened was,
he started cleaning up his
backlog and keeping it clean.
Then what happened was
the pressure came off his calendar.
Why?
'Cause people could get a response
within 24 to 48 hours by simply
sending the guy an email.
Huge change in his culture
simply because of his responsiveness.
By the way, the sensitivity
of a nervous system
pretty much indicates where
you are on the food chain.
So organizations that do not have
that kind of instant responsiveness
or people who don't
have that responsiveness
basically puts you further
down on the food chain.
Over the years I just found consistency
because the seeds, boy,
especially in my business,
seed planting is just amazing.
And it's probably true.
I mean come on, Stephanie,
that must be with your business
and anybody's out there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- With the restaurant, anything else.
It takes a while to build there
but you just got to stay there
and you got to keep
doing what you're doing
and keep putting one foot
in front of the other.
And that consistency, I think,
is something that also people,
that resonates with people.
- [Interviewer] I'm so glad you said that
because I'm always beating
my drum of consistency.
Do your marketing consistently
and you will get results.
And the whole seed planting,
it's just, I love that message.
- Yeah, I've had people
come back, boy, years later
sometimes eight, ten years later.
"David, I met you at XYZ da-da-da.
I'm now in this position right now.
You're exactly what we
need and holy mackerel.
How long did some of these seeds,
some of them pop right away obviously.
But you just got to
keep, Johnny Appleseed.
You just have to keep
spreading the seeds out there
wherever you can and whatever way you can.
A good friend of mine, Jack
Canfield, wrote Chicken Soup.
Jack's got the great story.
No publisher would take it.
He'd fill his trunk with the books,
and they did go around the
country, just talking about it
and taking every single radio spot
and interview that they could.
At some point it reached a critical mass,
it sort of tipped over.
And I think there's wisdom in that.
If you believe in what you're doing
and you love what you're doing,
just stick with it and
keep course directing.
Pay attention to feedback
and stick to your guns.
- In your first TED Talk you said
that the brain is not
necessarily good at multitasking
but it actually is a good planner
but it doesn't always know
what to be telling you at the right time.
For example three in the morning,
you're thinking about the guy at work
who you can't do anything about
but you said that in the long run,
your mind does plan things.
It plans reproductive
decisions, eating decisions,
and things like that.
- Yeah.
- Can you tell me a bit more about that?
- Well the mind naturally,
we naturally do a lot of that stuff
and all I did was recognized
what the process is
that we go through when we do that.
It is kind of interesting,
I don't know that I have the
solid answer to this yet.
Why everything I talk about
in the book is easy to do.
It's stuff we, in a sense naturally do.
You will naturally plan
the natural planning model is called that
because that's how,
that's how you got dressed,
that's how you walk,
that's how you talk,
you have an outcome.
You have a reason to be
doing what you're doing.
You have a vision of it being complete
and that then generates
all the potentially meaningful
things you need to consider
and then you sort those and organize them
and then you take an action.
So we're doing that all the time
and yet when people,
they don't really apply that same process
in much larger or more
complex kinds of things
in those kind of ways.
So it's really sort of like learning
from the smart part of us.
- Right
You deconstruct the smart part of us
and apply that to those longer
or those other pieces
that we don't seem to do the smart things.
- And then that too,
I just did a tweet 'cause
I was reminded of that
while I was doing another interview
that if you,
you need to make action
decisions when you're smart
so that when you're dumb
you do smart things.
Right, 'cause see it's the smart people
who really realize you're only smart
and inspired in very random moments.
So when you're smart and inspired
you want to use that to
capture the results of that
and then park the results somewhere,
where then when you're
kind of thick and stupid
which is majority of the time,
you actually do smart
stuff that you figured out
back when you were smart.
What happens if you got a whole
list of all the stuff to do
and you're not doing any of it.
Relax,
enjoy, have fun.
Procrastination simply is
not doing a bunch of stuff
and sometimes the thing
that you need to do
is stop doing anything.
As a matter of fact,
how good you are
at this getting things done methodology
is often indicated by how
well you could do nothing.
People have a hard time doing nothing.
But we know now in terms of brain science
that you need as much time
to let your brain relax
and be spontaneous and daydream
in order to refresh its
decision-making cognitive power
'cause you only have a limit of that
and so if you're not napping,
if you're not getting enough sleep,
if you're not backing off
and letting your mind
just relax and wander
then you're suboptimizing
your cognitive abilities.
Yeah, most people procrastinate though
because they're afraid of
stepping into something
you don't feel like you
can be successful at.
So just a simple idea of deciding
what's the very next
action I need to take.
Oftentimes people's lists
do not have next actions.
You'll see things like
on somebody's lists,
how many of you have something
that looks like a to-do list somewhere?
Anybody?
Yeah 99% of every to-do
list I've ever seen
is an incomplete list
of still unclear stuff.
You'll see things on
a to-do list like mom.
Oh good, well it's good historical data,
you probably had one.
Why did you write it down?
Oh well her birthday's coming.
Well great, what are you going
to do about her birthday?
I don't know anything about anything.
Right.
In most people's to-do list,
when you look at them
still are reminding you
there's decision-making and thinking
that you still need to do
about these commitments
and you don't have the
energy to think and decide.
So you say stop reminding
me I'm overwhelmed.
So your list become very
unattractive to you.
So there's lots of reasons
people may have a high barrier to entry
to start engaging with the
things that you're committed to.
Actually, mess is cool.
Actually the most productive times I am
is when I have the freedom
to make a creative mess.
You too.
You need, I need room to be crazy,
to make some mistakes, to
brainstorm, to be chaotic.
Go a little off the edge.
That is going to be your
most productive time.
It's when you have that
kind of freedom to do that.
However folks,
if you're already in a mess,
you ain't got room to make one.
If your kitchen's a mess,
you don't have time or the energy
to have a creative
dinner for your friends.
If your desk and your office are a mess,
you don't have room and
space to be crazy about
some new project and spread out
and have brainstorm with ideas.
If your email is backed up on you
with a thousand unprocessed emails
and you've got 3,000 other
things going on in your head,
you have no space to take
advantage of discretion
or a time that may show up
in terms of it being creative,
in terms of your energy.
The results of that,
if you're trying to use your psyche
to manage that mess and
you never get out of it,
is you get the results of two things
that are the critical elements
of self and organizational productivity.
You'll lose perspective
that is you'll lose the
ability to put your focus
where you need it on exactly
the thing you need it
at the horizon you need it.
And or you may be experiencing the results
of what happens when you lose control,
That is, I now don't have stability
and I don't have the freedom in my head
to be able to put the
appropriate attention
and execute on it when I do.
So those are the two key elements.
Folks, you can't manage time.
You don't mismanage five minutes
and come up with six.
The only time that you think
you need time management
is when one or both of these
two dynamics is suboptimal.
Either things need to
be more under control
or more appropriately focused.
If you map those two things together,
what do you get?
If you're, on the bottom left here,
we got no control and no focus.
Ever been there?
That's your basic victim experience,
driven by latest and loudest.
For the most part,
most of us are thrown there
by our own over-commitments
and creativity.
We're just trying to come up for air.
Now if that part of you shows up
that has high focus and
perspective but no control
now you're the mad scientist,
now you're the desperate artiste,
now you're the crazy maker
with all kinds of crazy ideas
and no constraints of what you're doing,
nothing very well organized.
Middle of the morning
you decide to go buy the new iPhone
but your IT department won't support it.
On the other hand,
you can get down on the weeds,
and say oh wait I need to
get 10,000 things organized.
I need to get all this cleaned up.
And now you get into micromanagement
if you don't have appropriate focus
you can get down on those weeds
and hung up on them like crazy.
And you spend a lot of time,
doing a lot of trying to
get organized about things
that may not be that important.
In the morning,
your crazy makers have got a new iPhone,
in the afternoon you spend two hours
of what could be a strategic afternoon
trying to set up the right ringtones.
Here's what's true about
all three of those, folks.
You ain't ready for
what's coming towards you.
You will be suboptimal
in terms of your ability
to handle the surprises
and they're coming.
Good, better, and different.
They're coming, trust me.
And you want to be optimally
available for those things
when they come to you.
It's great to complete things.
So that's a lot of,
we know when we finish anything,
there's a part of us that sort
of reaps energy out of that.
That feels good.
Those are your best days when you got,
you handle that, you turn that in,
you bought that thing,
you got, you fixed that,
you got the light bulb and screwed it in
and then it worked, then wow.
So those are your good days
when you actually finish a lot of stuff.
There's a lot of value to
completing an open-loop,
how and at the same time
you don't want to feel bad
if that loop is not closed.
And that's a lot of what
the GTD methodology does
is like, look you don't have
to finish all this stuff
in order to get it off your mind.
But you do have to identify what it is
and trust that you'll
see it at the right time
wherever you are with it,
at whatever its status is.
So yeah, you don't want to,
there's a whole new idea
that goal setting is really
not the best thing to do,
especially if you set a goal
and feel bad until you get the goal.
- Right. Okay.
- Because then you, then
you're not appreciating
the process of moving toward it.
And so you don't want to be able
to create frustration or guilt
or undermine your energy
by having some only future ideal win.
- Is goal setting just
as a pure exercise bad?
- No, you're setting goals all the time.
That's how you got
dressed, it's how you talk,
it's how you walk.
You're always, you're
seeing yourself out the door
and then you will fulfill the picture.
So we're setting,
you can't stop actually
because you're a teleological being.
You're always moving towards something.
There's a part of us
that's always attempting to
expand, express, fulfill,
complete something, just
look, just look around
just anecdotally anyway
that everybody's doing something
even when you're not doing something
you're doing that.
- Right.
- So there's an
intentionality still there.
- But like a goal of
I'm going to be a
billionaire in three years
da-da-da might not always be
the most productive thing.
- It depends on what you're doing with it.
It depends on whether it's running you
or you're managing that call.
Hey here's a picture, here's an image.
Let me just stick that in there.
Why not?
It's better to have nice positive
pictures and images in your head
than a bunch of negative ones
and as long as it creates expansion
instead of contraction
I think that's the big key.
That's something that I learned years ago
as a marker for me about
whether things are in alignment
at whatever level you
want to interpret that,
is engaging in this creating
expansion or contraction?
Love or fear?
So you can look at it that way.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Same thing. Right?
In loving, everything works.
In fear, nothing works.
So it's in a way,
it's just that that aspect of making sure.
So don't beat the medium.
And don't there's no reason,
there's no bad or good about
any of these kinds of things,
whether it's goal setting or not
other than is that the most optimal thing,
way to be engaging with it.
- Okay, and love or fear,
expansion contraction.
That's kind of a way and
you've got a gut feeling
whether you're opening
yourself up doing that
or whether you're protecting and limiting.
- Yeah and it's also a
good way for decisions,
like I don't know which way I should go.
Should I change jobs?
Should I move to Amsterdam, whatever.
Start doing, practicing,
rehearsing scenarios in your mind
about whatever that future scenario is
and see if that's feeling
expansive or contractive.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Eoghan Champkin asked me to.
I hope I pronounced that okay.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next.
Leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do,
I'd also love to know
what did David say
that really left its mark on you?
What rule did you like the best?
What clip really inspired you?
Leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shadow to Alejandro Baltazar.
Alejandro, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word.
It really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourselves.
And whatever your one word is,
much love.
I'll see you soon.
- I think over time
people develop their own signature
and I think it takes a while
to find out what your signature really is.
So I'll fast forward a little bit
where I am now.
We never really marketed ourselves
as I began to build a little company
around the success of the book
and brought in other trainers
and coaches and presenters
and started to build
some product around that.
Still not a huge company.
There are only 20 plus
of us doing that work
but we're partnering with
other people out there.
But as I started to do that
we really realized
that the brand had kind
of run out from under us.
GTD which was the shorthand
for Getting Things Done
became this global thing,
kind of like Kleenex and Xerox.
And we didn't own that.
I mean we owned it
but we, it was kind of
running faster than us
and we really had to rethink
how are we showing up
out there in the world
because people would meet me or meet us
and go wow you're nothing like
what I expected you to be.
I said well what did you expect me to be?
They said, well corporate,
left brained, and hardworking
and rigorous and disciplined and whatever.
And a lot of people go you know
I probably should but that's not me
but that's not us either
and so there was a disconnect
between how we were actually
showing up in the world
and people's perception
of us and the reality.
So we had a really smart guy
help us think through this.
And it's really about being authentic.
So those really tie together,
what's my signature
what's the David Allen signature?
If you go to my website now
if anybody ever saw it a year or two ago
it looks very different
now than it did then
because what we decided was,
look, take the tie off.
(laughing)
Because I'm really kind of a hanging out,
spontaneous kind of guy
which is really a lot of
what my methodology is about,
what the message is about.
But initially we had targeted the market
those are the people,
the high profile professionals
and fast track professionals
were the ones who were
probably in the most pain
in terms of overwhelm
and that could use the
methodology the most
to begin with.
But the truth is it's for anybody
and it's now spread around the world
with our signature.
In other words, our expression
is much more aligned
with who we really.
So we didn't really have to go anywhere.
Many times the problem companies have
is their marketing is a big "Tada!"
and they can't deliver on the big "Tada!".
Well our "Tada!" sucked.
We were delivering huge value
and people were having
transformational experiences
but it didn't look that way.
So we said well
there are a lot of
people we're not reaching
because there's kind of an inauthenticness
about what we were doing.
- [Interviewer] So that's been aligned now
within the website and a brand.
- Yeah yeah much more, much more so.
Whether it works as a business,
I don't know but it's
certainly a lot more fun.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I don't have to show them,
try to be somebody else
or have to deal with
people's perception of me
not being who I really am
and so maybe more
approachable lowering the bar
for people to be able to engage
and to engage with me.
Early on you have to kind of,
everybody probably gets
a nice business card
so that you look like you're bigger
than you probably really are.
You start to create an image
and a brand around
who we think we really ought to be
so we can attract people
and not turn them off.
But at some point
you really need to kind
of catch up with that
and allow yourself to just
kind of be who you are
and let the world come to you,
that are interested in you.
- [Interviewer] Okay, makes sense.
- But that has been as much
of personal development
development as a marketing
development on my side.
- [Interviewer] Okay, that's fascinating.
Another, again there's
two things happening here.
As you develop in a personal
element, the marketing,
those two things are aligned
and they're important for them both
to create a successful business.
- I think so but I'm not,
I haven't studied all
the successful businesses
to say that's how they did it.
I do know that in the
world that we're in now
because it's so transparent
and social media can
spread word like crazy
and you know that
essentially that transparency
the more authentic you are
probably the safer it's going to be
so you don't have to worry about
trying to be something that you're not.
Or gee, they followed me at that
and now I have to be that for them
and I have to be that for them.
- [Interviewer] It just makes life easier.
- It does make life easier.
Whether it makes it more
profitable I would think so
but yeah I think the world
gets attracted to authenticity.
- [Interviewer] I agree.
- And that's I think where the world is
because it's so transparent.
Inauthenticity I think shows up
at least subliminally if not directly.
So people out there
who are trying to create
marketing campaigns
that really aren't who you are
or trying to show up as something
that's just somebody's writing ad copy
but then your engagement with the company
doesn't hold up to that or
doesn't match with that.
That's tricky business.